Witch and you were playing that weird with the lady.
Like, Stuffy was playing with me too!
No, not that time.
Oh, not that one.
Okay, there were so many.
Sorry, I thought you were just playing with your lady.
And it was like some very questionable content.
Which one?
It was like insinuating a handy, I'm pretty sure.
Stuffy was with me on that too!
He was playing the same game with us!
In fact, we being there?
She was there!
No, I'm pretty sure you were like solo good.
No, no, no, no.
I...
no no no we're what is this game it's we got sponsored by
that's up do you remember that game that we got sponsored
together what was it oh oh oh oh that game like got like
deleted oh yeah and you were my test subject so basically
snuffy was like the experimental test subject for me because
we both got the same sponsor and so but she was first and on
youtube for that no yeah she got she because like it was it
was too gooner it was it was too gooner and then so then
they're like all right now that we know we cannot do that
let's let's fix the video edit on doki's channel before we
publish oh it was snowbreak it was snowbreak yeah my chat
said it was snowbreak yeah yeah so there was a moment there
where there's a lot of moments there you remember snuffy
there were a lot of moments he didn't give them a massage it
was like orc massage it was it was it was very risque but
then like you know conversely the last thing i watched from
mint was dave the diver which is based by the way but oh
yeah i love dave the diver i love dave the diver i'm
obsessed with it and i played dave the last thing i gotta
play that last thing you you did was actually with me right
it was the uh the metro chameleon i'm pretty sure that was
the last thing Yeah.
So, yeah.
Do I pause the test?
I mean, Doki's is quite powerful.
Because I watch the Twitch streams.
It's either Marvel Rivals or Gooner Game apparently.
Wait, you're willing to go on YouTube for Mint but not for
me?
I was like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't you stop.
The last time I streamed on Twitch was a month plus half
ago.
I try to go for Twitch streams if I can because that's just
where I'm going.
I happen to be but then sometimes I go on YouTube and it's
like hey hey mince playing Dave the diver and I'm like what
even is Dave the diver about fucking everything it's like 70
games in a trench code DLC is insane it's so it's it's it's
so good so it's it's it's it pretends to be a sushi
restaurant and yeah diving game but then it's like oh but
then there's actually you know you get the yakuza DLC and
now it's a side-scrolling yeah you get that you get the
Godzilla DLC and you can fight kaiju's and then you get like
if you go if you get the jungle dlc you can do like how many
dls are there animal crossing and then there's like an
animal crossing bit and then there's actual fishing fishing
it's great it's you got the fishing fishing i don't invite
it's really upset that we considered marvel rivals not a
gooner game by the way they're not i mean it is a little
it's a gooner it's like it's like it's like a bonus it's
just like a little like dessert you know The last thing I
saw about Marvel rivals was someone made a fan skin for
Jubilee and people thought it was real and her lips were
like all the way out.
And which ones?
People just believe that was real because it's the one
you're thinking about.
It's the one you're thinking about.
Well, the thing is, I mean, think about it, chat.
Think about, but like, you're not actually missing out
because it's third person.
So you're seeing the backside.
team if they have the same mod they get they get to have the
yeah yeah they get to enjoy enjoy it did they make big i
don't think i can look for yes there's like a there's like
inflation mods wait i'll show you it's true i've seen so
many people with the uh with the luna one what let's see
character models which which one is it actually i think i
have to like go into like the mod thing and then and then be
like yes i'm over 18 before i could see it that you like
accidentally put up when you were when we were playing left
for dead and you had like a mod that had nudity in it and we
didn't realize until the game started or something that was
who who was that that was no it was it was it was snuffy
like like a like a furry i don't know if it was luna or like
a fanat character but they had like nipple whipple i think i
don't know you know like i think it was like straight broob
like what did you get away with it i got away with that wait
so like nothing happened no no don't tell them about my go
live notification today either don't know坐 no wait wait no
wait no no wait wait wait wait wait what is no no no no what
is You can snitch to us.
Don't worry.
My stream's muted.
Yeah, my stream's muted.
It's not even live.
I'm not even live.
Yeah, yeah, I turned on my stream just for this.
I'm holding the power of just messaging everybody's phone,
like a little buzz.
So you're just like, maybe you're from Europe and you're
just waking up and you get like, oh, oh, what's that?
You know, you open up your phone, the screen lightens up,
your eyes are just unfogging and you just see, dick's been
hard for six years.
Oh.
Oh Happy birthday Also to my to my sound guys is the discord
audio better?
Sorry, I don't know is the discord audio actually yeah,
yeah, yeah, so I am muted just now I am muted just now You
say to your sound guys like like am I Hey on the set here on
the set Did you guys did you get it guys?
All right, this should have accomplished Let's cut next
scene yeah everybody's snuffy was just acting yeah she was
just and seen good job thank you thank you thank you this
menu is really gross by the way and also the actual text is
terrible i'm still trying to find a luna inflation mine
right i'm surprised i know right i'm surprised too I'm like,
I'm messing with the menu.
And like, there's just a setting here that just says feel.
And he just feels, feel smooth.
Oh, it's like, my options are smooth and low latency.
So I'm going to assume that's mouse acceleration.
I'm having to interpret it.
Wait, there is.
Maybe.
I'm turning it, I'm turning it to low latency.
To be fair, like, it's so hard to read this.
It's like ye old.
Yeah.
Are you kidding me?
I love it.
Are you okay?
the font the music's fucking awful as well it's just going i
had it muted for a bit all right let's see it's just like
maniacal strings i'll put it in the i'll put in the hangout
chat yeah so this is like a video you've been searching for
it this i thought i never i didn't lie i was very
transparent what i was
wow wow i don't i don't think i can share that with my chat
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna move on there's an invisible
woman by the way i am but i got a little distracted does it
affect your hip box yeah no no it's just it's cosmetic for
yourself if you play with that you just basically like fuck
yourself up because half of well over half of that model is
not actually the hitbox right okay yeah but you also can't
see like on your own so if you're playing all with it you
can't see nice nice because that's like covering to it
though yeah it's covering like one third wait let me find
the visible woman one you could have sent that to me and i
would have just believed that's what she looked like you're
like oh that's the character you like that and Yeah.
Honestly, I won't be surprised.
You guys want me to link it.
They're like, I want to...
Do you want fact-checked you?
Just be like, is it the right mod, you know?
Oh, okay.
So it's code joining, by the way, so don't capture until
we've joined the...
Oh, is it?
I'm like in the...
I made the lobby, but I don't know how to...
Oh, you did?
I don't know how to invite you guys.
It says join with code here, so maybe there's a code
somewhere on your menus.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
where am i i'm at simulation there's a where am i simulation
you're the one who wanted to play this yeah because i saw
where is this place i don't know where i am i'm in like a
simulation room i'm about to start a lobby just so i can
help you okay wait i found it oh my god no it's like you
found it it's like phasophobia coded like the oh so yeah
here the main lobby Okay, so there's like tier one crew.
Apparently it's like a roguelike too I'm having fun
listening to these maniacal strings.
I'm trying to find it.
I feel like I'm being thriller chased at the finale of a
movie.
Oh, I found wait I can't stop looking at that.
Okay, my thing is like for friends only so like even if the
okay Apparently there is a code and right in front of you,
but I don't know where it is right now Wait, so does that
mean chat saw the code they might have saw the code but you
can't draw In this one for me because I have to be my Steam
friend.
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it this?
But that just says burger.
No, that's not the code.
I- The super secret code.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna make my own lobby.
I mean- If I find the code before you, .
We're gonna do it.
No, we're gonna make my own lobby.
Alright, let's see.
Let's do a streamer run!
Who can find the code first?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That's right.
I'm looking.
Burger by burger.
We shall listen.
No, it's actually so trippy.
Like, I'm like, where the fuck am I right now?
I'm joining my own.
Oh, this is confusing as fuck.
I told you.
I'm not going to show chat.
Why is there a head on the desk?
I'm showing chat right now.
There's blackjack?
Wait, we can gamble?
Where's the room code?
Wait, there's actual blackjack?
Yeah, there's blackjack.
I'm looking for room code.
Yeah, there actually is getting distracted.
There's, oh my God, there's Uma Musume.
There's Uma Musume in the lobby.
What are you?
What?
I just, I just think you're fucking lying.
You're making shit up.
There's like, was it called the hockey, the disc hockey
shit, whatever.
What's the Facebook?
It's just like how the water's trending.
The frog's gay.
What is happening?
What are you talking about?
If you go, go, go.
There is a, oh, there's a kitchen over here.
There is, there's an arcade.
It's got, there's literally an arcade here.
How are you supposed to pick stuff up?
there's the Paragon?
What the fuck am I?
Where am I?
I don't know, man.
Wait, where's the code?
Wait, why did I have to find the code?
It's so fucking dark.
You can turn your flashlight on.
Can I just invite you to game?
Wait, you can just invite people to game.
No, fine, we gotta find the code, guys.
We gotta find the code.
Invite people to game.
I expect you to use the Steam friends.
I don't I don't freaking see no code.
No, neither do I.
I think you guys are going to invite us.
Massage area.
All right, let me invite you guys.
All right.
No, I'm looking for the code.
I'm going to find it.
Now, if I find it first, prepare for your next ship.
Why is this place so huge?
There's no code.
There has to be a code.
There's no way.
The code is a lie.
There is a code.
You guys are just not looking hard enough.
You're not really good at looking.
I mean, you've been in here longest.
I've just been chilling.
I was on, I was gambling.
Just been, oh, I'm in the simulation, yeah.
Yeah, see, I told you.
There's a closet here.
There's like, there's like my own room and everything.
We have our own room.
Have I been invited yet?
Oh, okay, so you go to the simulation and turn and go
forward.
I'm going to go all into hell.
And then there's the training.
There's the prepare the vessel.
Oh, that's me.
I can change everything.
I also fell into hell.
Wait, there's a hell.
Oh, that's a hell.
up guys I don't oh I am in hell I'm in hell how you get in
hell oh there's a simulation unstable wait I'm in the
simulation there's a training area dokey have you sent any
invites out yes yeah I sent out an invite just people
weren't was not accepting my invite so that's not on me
i i still don't have an invite i'm back to the cold embrace
of the night um oh i invited it doesn't show you to watch me
play it doesn't it doesn't show you're in game by the way so
you might not be able to invite us i clicked it you you you
played me like a fiddle i'm clicking on this i'm waiting for
dokey bird's broadcast to start i can't watch my stream
stuff Hey, you fucking clicked.
I was waiting for my input.
I clicked watch.
You just catfished me.
Yes, so can you watch my stream?
And you?
Wait, I got an invite.
Yeah, I'm getting invited to, getting and joining a game is
a fucking achievement.
That's echoing.
I hear voices.
Get out.
Are we going to use in-game?
Should we use in-game, boys?
We're going to use this game.
Am I in this game?
Wait, send me another invite, please.
Well, Lamo's in my game, so I'm doing something.
Send me an invite, please!
Yippee!
Send me another one!
I'm sending!
More!
More of my work!
Alright, wait.
I sent...
No, I'm another invite.
You know she's here.
Hello!
Please, please, please.
Thank you.
Hello!
Are we using in-game audio?
We want in-game or Discord?
You know what?
Let's just...
I don't know.
How good is the proximity?
I feel like proximity voice is always fun.
one second one second one second what did you do hello oh my
god we're all here all right guys you know the drill it's
time to turn down discord audio okay okay we're gonna do our
usual thing all right i need to write this down do i do that
do i just like mute myself no you just lower it on oh wait i
don't think lime who knows all right just mute ourselves
we're muting okay Hello!
I know, you deafened a while ago.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, no, it's fine.
Wait, what?
Oh my f- you- you are horrifying.
Hello.
We're all horrifying.
This is how we were- this is- It's how we were born.
Wait, how's my- Just shove X- and C to make noise.
Wait, can we spit in the food?
I think the worst part is this- Oh, I think the worst part
is just the fact that when I tab out, the sound is- I wonder
if I can fix that.
Yeah, I don't like that.
Doki, why do you have light coming out of your neck?
Oh, I have a flashlight.
You press F.
Oh, how do you...
Stuffy's not talking.
Stuffy, we can hear you.
I think you're on push to talk.
Oh, my God.
We're wearing flared pants.
That's amazing.
Oh, Stuffy, you need to go on a little diet.
Oh.
How do you...
fit also stuffy we still can't hear you uh x to spit where's
mint i don't i can't hear mint either she's over here i
heard mint earlier i think yeah be right back because she's
gone very still oh oh yeah there she is yeah but i need to
fix stuff real fast so i'm tabbing out i'm tabbing out so we
don't i won't be able to hear you guys all right sound guy
sound team is everything okay i'm using the game audio now
oh she's having a wasp problem oh she spilled her tea all
right let's see let me turn i'll turn up the game audio too
wait can you guys say something well not stuffy because we
can't hear her okay say something can you hear me now yeah
yeah i'm gonna oh i'm gonna cough on me somebody coughed on
me uh my character did that's kind of weird all right let me
try and push to talk if you can hear me after like i say now
let me know now
you think she heard you all right i mean so snuffy is mints
getting attacked by a wasp and snuffy's like a mute wait you
have to stuffy rejoin rejoin the room snuffy i heard it for
like one second too Does she like Stop spitting at me
I'm gonna I'm gonna fix my audio real quick too I'm gonna
turn it up A little bit more Were you guys able to hear
everybody earlier Or was it too quiet earlier I think maybe
when I discord crashed Um Like my settings also got reset
maybe I don't know I
Lion move sounded Sounded good earlier on Discord Like
before we got in-game voice Alright That's cool I had to up
my Discord up a lot though When What about like when before
Sound guy told me to up Discord Because I had to up it a lot
And me Oh Whoops Oh no I fucked up
Alright give me a sec and you fix my mic all right there you
go uh all right all right are we all good oh snuffy has to
rejoin all right wait how do you how do you chat rejoin we
will invite re we will re-invite you the same button so you
can figure it out yeah t is t yeah it's usually either t or
Or you hit enter.
How do I shove?
Oh, man, you're so quiet.
Huh?
Oh, never mind your lap.
She's not quiet.
Oh, she's just mumbling.
She was mumbling.
I'm mumbling.
All right, let me invite her.
Wait, man, I shoved you and the cloud of air came out like
brown.
Oh.
That's concerning.
It's because she doesn't shower.
Take a bath, free.
I mean, she's covered in...
Take a bath.
Goop.
Look at you.
Okay, it says you.
What do you mean?
you shove how do you shove oh if you know if you shower you
know oh i see the brown let's see yeah let's see if it comes
from ducky bird i bet so i bet so yeah it came out because i
touched you why it's because i touched you so you infected
me with the no you infected me you couldn't even touch me
you could barely no oh yeah bam what's that huh bam boom
spit on you too oh it was So much brown.
It's so much brown.
Did you spit on me too?
Oh, she needs to there.
How about all of us invite her?
Alright, we all invite Snuffy and let's see who she joins.
Naimo, invite Snuffy.
Okay.
Alright, we all invite her.
How do you invite her, though?
You just click on the arrow and invite to game.
Steam invite.
Yeah.
Oh, that way.
Yeah, we all invite her.
Oh, she's connected.
Oh, she's connected after I hit invite.
I just want to point that out.
Snuffy!
Ooh, she hates Doki.
No, it's because apparently it didn't work at first.
Snuffy, we can't hear you.
Where, what room is he in?
Oh, there she is!
Snuffy, can you hear us?
We heard it for like one second, too.
Have you checked the audio settings?
I mean, they're pointing to the right microphone Oh, yeah.
Well, she can't hear us, so you have to I mean, I can hear
it.
She just said she was having trouble because she was tapping
out to try and fix it.
And she was, like, losing audio.
Can you hear us?
How do you spit?
Oh, wait, she can hear us.
Wait, look at the audio setting.
Look at the...
Go to Options.
Go to Sound.
And then there's Push to Talk Off.
Yeah, I tried that.
Just double click.
We heard you for one second, Snuffie.
so some you were you were with us for one second just press
that on and off did you do it oh and then change your mic
settings dude go to options that I feel like I'm like
talking she's not deaf I don't know why I'm speaking louder
go to the one below push to talk and then adjust your mic
settings and just play around with it until we hear you
Like, I heard her.
Stop spitting her.
She can't even respond.
It's just bullying.
Oh, sorry.
She doesn't know.
Wait, I have an idea.
I haven't.
Have you fully restarted the game?
Wait, have you restart your PC?
I don't think...
I don't think you restarted the PC.
I don't think so.
Do you have a weird microphone set up, Snuffy?
Yeah, you have a weird microphone.
We could make it...
We could just do, like, mute, and then she'll talk to us via
Discord.
We could...
We could just only use Discord, to be honest, as well, if we
need to.
No, we could just do a mute, and then she'll talk to us on
Discord.
She'll be, like, the omnipresent presence.
All right.
I'm mute.
I'm undefining, but putting on mute.
All right.
Snuffy, say something.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, well, she's alive.
I'm just going to talk to myself.
on discord all right well I can hear you yeah we're gonna
talk in game and no no we're talking in game and then yeah
yeah yeah so snuffy is like the managers well now they
snuffy as the manager so she knows I can't hear you guys now
wait you can't hear us what you can't I can't hear you what
are you tabbed out of the game are you tabbed
She doesn't want to hear the voices anymore All right guys
you didn't believe I come with me come with me.
I'll show you the arcade Come with me you guys didn't
believe me It's right here Look at that like hear me right?
Yeah, I can hear you stuffy Look, look blackjack right here
It's blackjack and then oh my musume wait actually i can't
nobody believe me just like the game unbothered deborah is
gonna win it all how do i queue it up i need to i need to up
snuffy's volume a little all right snuffy's volume's been up
25 dollar increase me all right we have no cash we don't we
gotta make money we gotta make money so we can gather all
right guys oh wait we can change our day job so we can we
can gamble it all we know how to work our job oh that's the
simulation don't touch that don't touch this it's greasy i'm
gonna change my outfit is this guy alive is he dressed as a
cow he's dressed as a cow wait i don't know i'm i'm i got it
i got it oh oh i don't have anything i'm poor oh wait i'm
poor Wait, wait, thread the needle, thread the needle.
What are you guys playing?
Oh.
No, no.
Hold on.
Give me one second.
Where are you guys?
Oh, are you guys playing air hockey?
Just around the rim.
Around the rim.
Oh!
Wait, did you get a point?
I got a point.
It says- It says one!
It says one!
No!
There is a ghost!
You're taking over my game!
Yeah!
Stop!
It's a fair game!
Oh!
Oh, a ghost!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, you!
You sabotaged me!
That was a gift from God!
It's the God of hand!
The hand of God!
It's the hand of God!
What's this one?
Oh, the sound guy helps stuff you up, but let me know if
it's better.
Oh, that's just cool.
It's just cool.
It's like we're in the VR chat world right now with all the
mini-games in the living room.
It does feel like that.
Oh, there's a soda.
Whoops.
Makes me buzz.
It's chat.
I should drink one.
Oh, there's a confetti cannon.
Oh, that was art.
To throw.
Oh, what?
You sound, why does it sound like that?
I get like overstimulated within about 30 seconds of joining
the lobby.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
It's true.
Every game has a basketball now.
Are you guys ready to work our day jobs?
Getting buzzed and throwing balls.
Oh, I see.
This is just our chill area.
and then we actually go down to hell to work i see can i
hold my training section over here we don't need a train we
can do this train okay i'm ready let's go we're going to
hell okay oh okay all right do i just queue up oh i think i
died no no are we not did you fall into the pit yeah we're
in the pit we're being reborn that's sad be reborn to be
fast food workers but goonga okay all right this looks like
five nights of reddies okay what is that thing oh this is
the roguelike part where we can upgrade so we can upgrade
our stuff that's cool yeah okay affixes so this is this is
like overcooked but gross but like roguelike work for money
oh you can hire in people to help you out but we don't have
money all right how do we start the game nothing in stock
we'll work for money i love to nothing in stock i guess i
guess we just start the simulation then how do we start it
so much and you guys sound like robots choose a how do we
choose a contract wait oh we have to choose one of these oh
we have the worst one there was a good Oh, well, it's all
right.
It's all right.
We're good.
Here we go.
Wait, there's already an order.
There's already an order, you guys.
Oh, there I go.
We gotta go.
We have 50 seconds.
What is happening?
Okay, wait.
I'm going in.
I'll take the order.
What do you want?
Re-close out, Dougie's like, no, I don't want to be able to
run today.
Jungle Cola freeze.
We need one Jungle Cola freeze with a peppery blast.
Summer's sweater's choice.
Where's the soda?
Summer's choice.
Summer's choice is awful.
Jumbo, jumbo.
We don't need to trade.
That'll be fine.
Jungle, we can.
We can do this!
We're good at this!
Where even is all that?
Oh, those are all just drinks.
Oh, I found it!
Okay, I found it out too.
I just got a number of colds, too.
Oh, peppery breast.
What did he get?
What do you...
Okay.
Peppery breast, swimmers, toys?
Peppery breast.
They're all drinks!
Next.
Wait, where's the peppery breast?
I found peppery.
Oh, shoot.
Don't worry, where is peppery breast?
Where?
I need to get that up.
Okay, wait, what do we do?
What are swimmers choice?
What is that?
That's a drink!
Who's on drinks?
We're all on drinks!
Where's the cup?
I have that, but where do I give it to?
Collect, it must be here, right?
Peppery breast, top bun hot sauce, pickles, bacon, chicken
potty, lettuce and buns.
Are we gonna be okay?
Chicken potty?
Oh.
Who's making the burgers?
I got, I got, she doesn't want burger.
I just got drinks.
Alright, here's another drink.
I'm so confused it's okay.
We can do this.
I think nobody's nobody's making a burger No, we don't need
a burger.
It's just drinks.
It's peppery breast.
Peppery breast is not a drink It could be the grill.
The grill is nice.
What is the grill?
This is the grill.
There you go.
We found it Okay, turning it on.
I'm grilling.
There was also training.
There was a lot of fun Okay, I got the bottom bun lettuce.
I need lettuce Wait, is it this before I press is this a
chicken or fucking sandwich menu and what it what on earth
is going on?
Chicken patty guys, I think why is there a collision?
Guys, okay, I got how do I know when it's doing better?
Okay, chicken patty.
sure i think we get a burger chicken patty guys where's the
chicken patty we need it we need a chicken patty how do you
make a chicken patty i'm grilling one i'm grilling a chicken
patty okay i need the rest i think we're doing great guys
times two i need two bacon i have two bacon's here we don't
need bacon well we need chicken we're doing an order it has
to be an order oh we need the chicken then we need the
chicken first stuffy oh okay it's on the grill i think ready
i don't know really that's the way that's a bun bottom
that's not a chicken that's bun bottom yeah you guys you're
grilling a burger bun where's the chicken there's no no this
is fries this is surprise um how do i what's it there oh
this is chicken it's ice okay we got oh this is chicken this
is chicken right here this is cookies these are cookies lima
why aren't you oh yeah i found the chicken i found the
chicken did you yes yes lima you're oh no someone was not
looking very well Hold on a second the jungle cola freeze
and the peppery breast is so good.
Oh my god.
I got the I got the I've got the chicken breast I'm doing it
The growth on fire pickles pickles too.
Oh, no, what do we do?
Pickles pickles pickles.
I'm making my burger right now and then a hot sauce Is there
anything to prevent fire safety?
What is that?
I think I think it's fine hot sauce and a top one.
I got I got the burger I made the burger.
I made the burger.
The fire is getting worse.
When does it become a problem?
How does she accept my order?
You think the freezer are putting it out.
Where's the...
The building is begun to cook itself.
It's fine.
We're from hell.
We're fine.
Okay.
Don't forget this.
Don't forget customer.
Don't forget.
No, that's fake news.
Nice.
Agent Gordon's soda.
She wouldn't take my burger!
Deep Sea Sammy.
Order reading at lobby.
Agent Orange and Deep Sea Sammy.
Oh, that's fine.
These are...
I got it.
Those are drinks.
We need a fish paddy?
A freezer burst open.
Can somebody grill us a fish...
A freezer?
A freezer.
Yeah, I got you.
Guys, why didn't we do the tutorial?
I hate you.
It was Lyme's suggestion not to.
Yeah, I know.
I hate you too.
wants us to like once it looks so good in front of everybody
so she made us not do a tutorial i got the the fish patty
why don't we put the fish patty okay that was peppery breast
what's a deep sea sammy i don't know oh you did it you made
it i oh a bag nice guys i think we're doing really i think
we're doing pretty good not gonna lie okay i found the
recipe for a deep sea Sammy I need a fish patty I got it I
got it serve the wrong order that's the chickpea I didn't
know it was the wrong burger I got the fish patty I got the
fish patty dude he got an order and he's still waiting he
just wants a free order I mean we did fuck up his order I'm
getting the agent um I mean the order is still there
Nobody's grilling.
No, I'm grilling.
I'm grilling.
Why is there just a frozen piece of fish on my desk?
That's that.
No, that's cooked.
It's cooked.
Sorry, manager.
Okay.
Why?
Wait.
I'm turning everything on.
That's not how that works.
I don't know which meat is for which.
So we gotta figure this out.
I fucked up.
Wait, I'm okay.
Okay, I got the...
You're the only reliable one.
Yeah, you're the reliable one.
How do you fuck up?
I need more fish.
I have a fish.
fish cooked right here i got it okay slap that fish on the
burger
onions i'm i'm on grilling two minutes to make one burger i
believe in us timer's going up it's going up yeah yeah for
every job what well done we do it goes up oh wait i did it i
mean five second roll deep sea salmon put it in there put it
in there i have i have please put that Oh, you got him.
You got it.
Yeah.
We did it.
One burger.
One burger of the day.
I got it.
Yippie.
Okay.
Yeah.
You, you.
I'm going to do it.
I got this.
All right.
Agent Orange.
I have so many patties.
And a mother clucker.
There you go.
Thank you.
All right.
We have, what's mother clucker?
Is that the, I have a chicken right here.
Wait, is this a chicken or is this a chicken?
Like, this is the bottom bun.
God, that's complicated.
Are you making it over there, then?
This is the chicken.
I got the chicken right here.
Could I, I can, I just want to be useful.
I'm just grilling as many types of meat as possible.
Jungle cola for you.
Thank God you don't have to cook the bacon.
Chicken.
Is this chicken?
I can't tell what this is.
The chicken is this one.
This is the chicken.
Wait, no?
Have you put the chicken on?
Yeah.
I've got chicken here.
Order up.
onions how do you do the uh order out oh soft yeah you just
grab them i've already did the drinks mayo hot sauce hot
yeah mother clucker yes one mother clucker hot off the
gritty is it in there it's in there it's in there
we're working over town boys because We're doing such a good
job.
Oh, shit.
Dairy fairy.
Oh, wait, where's our...
Oh, I found it.
Gr- Grief?
What is it?
And peppery.
Are we... Am I scared?
Am I scared?
Wait, I don't know what's gonna happen.
I have...
I'm chicken.
Should we leave the simulation before it breaks apart?
Is that what we should do?
I think we're fine.
We can make...
Because there's a code of met lever here.
Oh.
Can we do it?
Yeah.
There you go.
Wait, get the hell out of there.
Get the hell out of there.
Oh, my God.
Guys, guys, do you remember where we live?
Where do we go?
Where's...
Where's the...
Where did we...
We're here.
Here, here, here.
I remember.
It's here, right?
It's here.
Hey, why are we living in a situation?
Wait, I think we have to do the objectives.
I think we have to do the objectives.
Oh, my God.
We didn't close the restaurant.
We didn't close.
We didn't lock the door.
Yeah, we need to close.
Oh, my God.
I need to extinguish the fire.
Oh, there's objectives.
Oh, my God.
The trash disposal.
Uh, restock the kitchen.
How do we restock the kitchen?
I got the trash.
I have no idea.
Where's all the fucking fire extinguishers gone?
Okay, I got the trash.
I got one in my hands.
Okay, I got one.
Oh, my God.
We're...
Someone's getting trash!
Send it to me!
Okay, I think the fires are done.
Yeah, wait, no, they're not.
The kitchen.
We'll get the others.
Oh, we gotta restock the kitchen.
I heard like a demon.
Yeah, oh, oh, yeah, there is.
Oh, there is a demon.
There is a demon.
It just has food in my right.
Where does the cheese go?
There's a demon!
Oh, yeah, I mean, yeah, ignore what Doki said earlier about
the demon.
How do you reset?
Lai-bo, how do you do this?
Where is it?
Oh.
my god oh my god wait i found it i got the bakery stop
the simulation is collapsing what do i have right now okay
no i'm cooked
i'm cooked i'm alive i am also cooked
leave i hope i don't know why didn't we do the tutorial can
we leave
why didn't we do the tutorial i don't know man this is i
guess i was just too gung-ho about the whole thing i
literally saw you get bored
That was so scary.
That was...
I thought the...
I thought cooking the burgers was hard.
Oh, my God.
I have my tablet open.
Luigi wins by doing nothing.
I did.
Why did they get...
Why did not me?
No, I didn't either.
I think that's just our dead body.
That's me on my tablet.
I'm employee of the week.
Oh, of the week.
I was stuck on my tablet.
Alright, alright.
So there is a...
I think I'm going to burn some fungus on my body now.
There is a tutorial right here.
I think we should do the tutorial, guys.
I think we got it now.
I'm smoking from this burger bomb before we do the tutorial.
I gotta enter my ship.
Yeah.
Yes.
All right, let's have a look.
Yeah, I think it's just like, so you can familiarize
yourself with it a little bit.
So you can be like all these little sauces and things like
that.
Yeah, I drank some beer.
I pre-gamed before I went to work.
Oh, wait, this is it.
I didn't smoke, too.
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's clothes.
I can be naked.
Wait, I know there's like a...
I'm already naked.
Wait, you can?
There should be a broom for us to like clean this.
Wait, okay.
I don't have any sort of...
I've never done anything in my life to qualify for.
I can be Burger Chan.
You can be Burger Chan.
Burger Chan.
Or is it soft?
Oh, this is for takeout.
Is there a mop?
It should be.
I think I guess not in the tutorial.
You don't give it to you for the tutorial.
It's a mop.
Whoa, what's happening in here?
It's like a filled drink so you can so you can clean it
later.
Am I stuck in the corner?
There's an unstuck.
Wait, is there there's a bottom right?
There's an unstuck thing.
guy has like dirty ass oh this guy too why did you spit on
it stuffy i was cleaning that i was doing spit shine i'm
okay where's that would do i spit on him i think she's doing
the tutorial yeah
wait this is not live i think i think it's taken i think
it's training and that you can just Familiarize yourself,
the tutorial is the thing we skipped at the start.
Oh, no, it's in the start of the menu.
You get used to, like, the mechanism of making things.
Yeah, I watched it.
Because, like, all the stuff is here.
It was kind of confusing.
You know what, guys?
I think we know what we're doing now.
I think we can go do another shift, honestly.
Are you guys ready to go to hell?
I just, I think, I think the thing we're going to struggle
with is I don't know how to clock out.
Don't worry.
We're going to know now.
We do our objectives, and then we're good, I think, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess so.
Yeah, now we know how to make burgers.
Should we be all...
Should we be all on Discord?
Because it's kind of weird, like, only being able to hear
some people and then other people aren't fading out.
It's actually fucking me up.
Alright, well, I'll go on Discord then.
Then you guys can't drink and hear how fun you sound in your
buzz.
I didn't hear any difference.
No, I heard it.
I see I heard the robot.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, I see.
Whoa!
If you press, I'm stuck, you get TP.
I got TP'd out.
Oh, I was wondering what...
it did all right all right i'll go back to the discord are
we switching the discord then yeah yeah yeah i think i think
it makes more it's kind of like it feels weird it's like two
separate conversations almost hello hello i'm on discord i
know me too let me adjust this all right sound get audio
audio adjust everything again
wait someone is not oh you're still open mic mint Yeah,
you'll need to put it on push to talk man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that we can't hear you again
Yeah, I don't see a thing that says like clock out.
So I feel like maybe we just do the I feel like we hit the
lever and then do the Yeah, we have to run to these and then
run.
Yeah.
Yeah, there might be like a thing that we have to press
After we run in or something guys.
Are you guys ready to go in clock in?
Yes.
Yes, let's do it.
We got this We got this.
I believe.
Are we clocked in?
I can't tell.
Oh, we're just coming down.
I think it like waits for everyone to get in there.
Yeah, I was going to say.
My bad.
Who's missing?
I'm lost.
Wait, where do we go?
We're in hell.
Where did Snuffy, oh my god, I just see Snuffy exploring the
lobby.
I didn't know I had to queue up.
Where do I go?
Yeah, jump in the hell.
Jump in the hell.
Okay, I'm in.
Take two.
The first one's great.
a warm warm-up yeah yeah yeah burger by burger we shall
ascend yeah yeah now we know where things are yeah yeah in
the back of my brain i didn't like me too all right someone
else choose the contract i up okay you don't even know
what's happening you can only see this modifier kitchen area
the glitch has never stopped paranormal disturbance well
both of those suck but i feel like the mayhem would be worse
because we already don't know what we're doing yeah i can
jump higher because i smoked a cigarette i don't know what's
happening i'm ready is that Oh.
Alright.
We're ready to get started.
Alright, I'm on.
Oh, maybe this is where we clock out.
I'm on a wonderful day.
I'm on burger duty.
Little B.
We got one little B.
One little B.
I need to, like, collaborate on burger stuff because the
orders aren't that complex.
Alright, I'm grilling burgers.
Yeah, I'm grilling burgers for us.
Salmon nuggets.
Swimmers.
Swimmers choice.
Alright, burger stuff is here.
I have a fish.
I got the swimmer's choice.
Fish is done.
Okay, little B is really, really simple.
Can I do little B please?
Okay, you do the little B, you're grilling.
I'll do a little B.
I need a beef patty.
Beef patty on there.
Fine, it's all the way there.
It's raw, it's fucking raw.
They're all cooked right here.
This one's raw.
Not this one, the one's here.
They're right here.
There isn't anything there.
You've thrown them into the freaking thing.
It doesn't show up anymore.
Whoops.
I got one now.
That's my bad I get some cheese.
I'm getting the little B on little B almost ready Little B
almost ready Order up.
Sam, little B put her in the bag.
Yeah, there she is in the bag The grill is on fucking fire.
I got it.
I'm gonna put them on the floor Kitchen manager.
I got it out of the way Lime who put the B in the bag.
I put the B in the bag.
Do we have salmon nuggets and and the swimmer's choice okay
I have fish no we need salmon nuggets we need the salmon
nuggets who's got salmon nuggets I don't know how to make
nuggets I just know how to make meat it's supposed to be in
here right what's a salmon choice is a drink apparently yeah
I already got that it's in there yeah we need salmon nugget
yeah salmon nugget I'm gonna put some I'm gonna start
putting me on the floor because it doesn't matter nugget
okay Salmon nugs.
It's under fried food.
All right.
This is pie.
Where is the food, though?
Yeah, where do you find it?
Salmon nuggies, salmon nuggies.
I don't know, but I'm doing my job.
What is this?
Raw pie tray.
Nope, that's not what I want.
Um, hello.
Fries.
And we found the salmon nuggies?
I found the nuggs.
We have not found the nuggs.
You didn't?
They're under the fries.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
I'm cooking them.
I'm doing my job Oh, these take a while Oh my god Doki, why
is there meat all over the floor?
Because it doesn't matter It's because you guys were saying
you can't find the meat Just I see Just try and find if you
need meat Look it down Look down Oh, now it's on Kitchen
manager here Kitchen manager here It's okay, we don't have
help inspectors It's just a simulation Wait, is it done?
I need to boost up the audio a little bit It looks like it's
it's on it looks pretty pretty Toasty do keys audio guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, suck my cock
That what I got the salmon nuggets.
I thought you said you found but they're not oh they're not
they're done They're both done.
They're both done.
Put the nugs in the thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I didn't give it to them.
Yeah, serve it, serve it.
Nice Yes All right their parties all over the day because it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter just crash down and pick
them up nobody cares that it touches the floor they're
simulations they're not real you are gonna clean this all up
when we close or you are fired that is insane you have
ruined this business you're not even a manager we're all
minimum wage workers okay I'll get the swimmers it take my
job very seriously is it done I have to do the ice to take
the order oh ice first okay yeah yeah there you go agent
orange in a bag i got a bunch of food in the bag what's the
other we need burger burger burger burger burger burger how
you make burger oh burger burger burger is bottom bun beef
patty i got the beef patty right here but that's like a man
talked to me did anybody else talk to a man yeah it's just
the paranormal activities don't worry about i'm making the
burger burger i'm doing your job normal activity look the
the chairs are floating.
Where?
Did you put the lettuce on before the cheese?
I don't think you, is there lettuce on there, Doki?
Yes.
Stop littering.
Stop littering in our yard.
Why, this is the most uncertain I've ever heard you sound.
If I look at the screen that lists everything, is it going
to say lettuce on it?
Yes.
How do we, how do we run the world from the ghost?
Is it going to say lettuce on it as I'm looking at it in
real time?
put lettuce on anything.
Go get the parasite.
Put the burger in the bag.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
Yeah.
It says weird sandwich.
That's not the right thing.
Oh no, you fucked up the order?
Who fucked up the order?
Who fucked up the libel served the wrong order?
You mean you put the things on wrong because you lied about
lettuce.
I don't want to lie.
Why would you lie about lettuce?
I did not want it.
I am looking out for the customers.
I don't want people that have diarrhea parasites.
I am a fucking zero.
You put the lettuce on.
That's good.
Yeah, I put the lettuce on.
Oh, you have pickles.
And now mayo.
You put some mayo and a top bun.
There you go.
Perfect.
Perfect as, like, just like the first burger I made.
Burger, burger.
Here's a burger, burger, burger.
Burger, burger in here.
Ready.
Alright, there you are.
Bigly, pigly.
What do we need?
I put the bottom bun.
Salmon nuggets.
I can make the burgers if you want.
Well, someone asked to make the burger.
I was cooking the burgers.
I'll make the burgers.
Let me like bigs and pigly.
Trust me, she took over my burger job.
I don't trust you.
I don't think anybody should trust you.
It's either take over your burger job or what you make
burgers, which sounds really boring.
Can I have a pork patty?
Is that a pork patty?
Wait, I got the chicken patty.
my god oh my god it got immersed in the cheese it's right
here it's right here i got the park yeah there you go see
i'm doing my job better than you're doing my job oh my god i
mean if you want to put the meats on the burgers that'd be
great because i can't tell what's what because it's all over
the goddamn floor the 50 burgers on the floor indicates It's
not a good job.
I'm gonna say it.
You don't know shit, Stubby.
What is your job?
You don't know shit.
You don't know what you're even doing.
I'm fighting the paranormal right now.
Bigly, pigly in the bag.
Do we need drinks?
Because I've got a drink here.
Do we got the Nuggies?
We good?
We're great.
Fantastic.
Perfect.
Good job, everybody.
Bigger, bigger, bigger!
Bigger, bigger!
Another coffee customer!
A burger burger, mother cooker!
A burger burger!
Okay, okay, okay, I got the chicken.
That's a fish.
Wait, snuffy!
I need lettuce.
Lettuce goes on here.
I got chicken.
Where did you find the salmon that gets at?
Oh, it's in here.
This is beef.
Oh, okay, okay.
I got the beef.
That's pork.
Put the beef.
I got the beef.
That's chicken.
Burger burger, mother cooker.
Two burgers?
I think we might need fresh beef.
I might need beef.
Two burgers?
Yeah, we need beef.
Mother clucker mother clucker There's chicken over here,
there's chicken over here This is a burger burger I got
beef, I got beef She's got beef, she's got beef I got beef,
she's pushing, she's pushing Cheese, cheese Who is hitting
the building, can I help you?
Oh my god I mean You need chicken, I have chicken right here
I do not need chicken on this burger Who needs chicken?
I need chicken I make your burger here I got the chicken
right here.
Burger, burger, Dylan.
I put the fries in the bag.
Where's the bag?
Bag.
Burger, burger, in the bag.
Okay, we just need a mother clucker.
I gave her the chicken.
I'm assembling.
She's assembling.
Leaf, patty.
Oh, wait, no, that's the wrong thing.
Don't worry, I'm making more chicken.
Mother clucker.
We're doing so good, guys.
I think one of us is going to get promotion.
It's not going to be you guys.
A ghost just stole my fish.
Well, thanks.
Well, I was fighting the paranormal.
But now I'm assembling the mother clippers.
I have more meat on the floor.
I'm entertaining the customers with dance and song.
Oh, she's dancing.
Wait, Min's not doing her job.
Oh, dear.
What does that mean?
Oh, it's fine.
It's just the little liches.
It's just the paranormal.
It's just Min inviting her friends over at the party.
You think I have friends over to invite?
You got this.
Is that a mother clipper?
Get out of my way, everybody.
Get out of my way.
She assembles one burger.
She thinks she's God.
This is the manager.
Yay.
It's true.
Customer's waiting.
Yay.
Mother clucker, dairy fairy.
We're so good.
I'm doing the mother clucker.
I'll get the menu.
You'll get the dairy fairy.
Okay.
And I'm gonna jerk off in the break room.
Oh, good.
I'm the soul to the customer.
I'm the fairy fairy.
What did I do?
Wait, I'm the one.
I've never made a burger before.
Is it hard?
A lot of people in mine.
Oh, it's not too bad.
Where's the chicken?
Mustard.
Do we have chicken anywhere?
Yeah, we do.
It's on the floor.
Oh, they just come out of the security thing.
You don't know.
I do not see the chicken here.
Did the ghost eat the chicken again?
I think the ghost eat the chicken.
The ghosts really like chicken.
One, two, three.
Bacon beef.
I'm...
You're having the chicken now.
I need a beef.
I need a beef right now.
It's on the floor.
Is that a beef right there?
I got chicken right here.
Oh, it is.
It is.
Oh my gosh.
Chicken.
I told you they're on.
It's this one.
This one.
Chicken.
I'm making the dairy fairy, by the way.
And then I want bacon.
I need bacon.
Did you do bacon?
Bacon is right here.
You don't need cooking.
Stability is suffering a bit.
Wait, I made a weird sandwich.
What do I do with this?
Throw it in the middle Fucked up the sandwich
Yeah, you forgot to put three cheese, did you?
No, I did put three cheese?
You forgot to put three cheese?
No, I didn't!
I didn't!
Oh shit, do we should close up?
Are you guys rolling out there?
We should close up!
No, we don't, we haven't made our quota yet, I don't think.
Yeah, but we have several things.
I saw fireworks, I think we met it.
I think we met it.
No, no, it's not.
Oh The dairy fairy needs to go in there.
The mother clicker is done.
I'm working on it.
I'm working on it She fucked up the dairy fairy She fucked
it up I'm working on it No!
Come out of my way!
Onion and mustard I got the mustard Put the onions on
Mustard and then Top bun Oh god, oh jeez Dairy fairy
Everything's floating I'm trying to keep it.
Oh my god.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
Wait, where'd the person go?
We should we should we should leave.
We should leave.
I think we're waiting at the lobby.
Can we close up?
Before we have a couple days or we just fought.
I think we maybe we have multiple days, guys.
Maybe.
Right, but I can't push this lever.
I don't know about you.
Oh, let's okay.
Maybe if we take one more art order, we might be able to we
might make the quota.
Jungle.
I got the jungle quota freeze.
Why the dokey assault?
The customer.
What did I do?
I was in the house.
I was yelling at you.
It might actually attribute everything to Doki.
That might be what it's doing.
Someone else is... I think she's liable.
I think she's liable.
Someone is sabotaging me.
Maybe Snuffy has sold to the customer.
I did not do that.
I just want to attract like a good Sumeritan.
Are you kidding?
What the heck happened?
You want to go?
I got so much.
I'm the manager.
Yeah, I do want to go.
Peppery breast.
Wait, you're giving me a concussion.
I need chicken breast.
I got chicken patty right here.
Watermelons.
Is it raw?
No.
It's raw.
No, these are, I think, they're uncut lettuce.
I think one of the guests is a ghost.
They keep levitating the chairs.
I need to, like, it's got to be this guy.
Get out of here.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we gotta figure this out.
All right.
Uh, extinguish fire.
Okay, I'll do that.
I got the trash.
Jesus Christ.
I got the fire.
I'm doing fires too.
Ah!
Oh.
Trash taking care of.
I tried to do it.
Fire taking care of.
Wait.
Calibrate.
Ah!
What the?
There's a thermostat?
Turn off kitchen appliance Did you get instantly I sort of I
was really proud of myself For helping me Helping the
extinguishing fires And I walked into the monster Because I
was very proud of myself Don't get me No please let me go
home Let me go home Wait Stop it Oh We died Alright so we
got everything but I just realized I've been streaming an 8k
hold on you like pushing people while they're AFK
it's me I'm the employee of the week okay wait I'll be right
back before we start Okay.
Okay, all right.
Wait, while Stuffy's fixing it, we go to the arcade, guys.
It's going to be the arcade.
Oh, we have a little bit of money.
We can blackjack.
Okay, are we...
How do we have money?
We die.
I'm in.
You're in?
Yeah.
I'm...
Wait, you used to bother money.
No, I didn't.
Yes, you did.
I can't go in.
Oh.
Hit.
Why are there 20 stages on this fucking grill?
Yo, you lost it.
Alright, well, Min lost us, lost all our money.
I'm in.
How do you still have money?
I had $66.
Who gave you $66?
Because I'm a good worker.
Oh, yeah, you were.
Oh, hit for sure.
I'm yeah, I'm standing Boost up Alright, yeah Boost up
everybody Stop fucking gambling our money away But at least
doing something productive Like betting on horses Don't tell
me what to do with my money I'm gonna go with Chief
Spaghetti All in on Chief Spaghetti Oh, do you guys hear
Skibbity Riz Won the next horse race The last horse race
again They're two-time champs Yeah, Skibbity Riz is a
two-time champ how does it go oh they're off they're off oh
cheese spaghetti cheese spaghetti cheese spaghetti cheese
spaghetti oh cheese spaghetti i bet everything on you please
please oh cheese spaghetti oh cheese spaghetti third place
you're bad at this talk bad about my horse again that's
right you lost every all right bet bet on bet on another
horse i'll bet against you i will i will i will if i messed
oh wait that's steve i don't want to be where's spaghetti
back to back skibbity riz what's up apparently you push each
other too lot push each other too long you get you get dazed
lord so it's you got an energy mint mint mint push me
against the wall and got me dazed earlier damn sorry where's
line i didn't mean to i have one you guys look what i found
This is how Limeu snaps.
I think...
He ripped the gambling.
Set it all on fire, Limeu.
Set it all on fire.
This is how she snaps.
This is what minimum wage work does to her.
This is what Doki Bird does to her.
What do you mean?
What did I do?
No, Blackjack.
Guys, guys, I think this time we got this.
how you kill the man guys yeah i pushed that guy and he died
i don't know hey stop showing me who did you this guy dokey
bird injured toe apparently why did you do that that guy in
particular and this guy i gotta smoke before my shift all
right guys are you guys ready i got my nicotine high okay i
want to play b-ball real quick wait where where's me is me
playing b-ball you're playing b-ball expelling fire
everywhere We're balling?
We're balling.
We're balling?
I'm in hell and you guys are balling?
We're just waiting in hell.
Stop.
I win.
I was even playing against you.
I won.
1v2.
I can't count.
1v1.
Oh, 2.0.
2v1.
I'm having a stroke right now.
She can only play basketball guys.
She can't do anything else.
Come on.
Just score a shot.
We're waiting for you.
I'm trying.
I can't.
Yeah, we're waiting for her.
I am.
We're waiting for you.
You are there too.
Yep, I already won.
Look, I helped her.
See, this is why I just, I was helping her win.
But get over here.
We have to start our shift.
Oh my, she can't stop bowling.
I can't stop.
We are stuck in hell.
I'm taking this with me.
Chris,
I gave her an assist.
Alright, we got this.
We just, we almost figured out how to close shop.
We're becoming more and more efficient per ride.
Oh, I don't even like it.
Ooh, what do we got today?
The tow is taxing everybody now.
All shop items are doubled.
Well, that doesn't matter.
We've never even gone to these fucking shop items, so
whatever.
Order timeouts have and customers arrive 30% faster.
Let's go for the tariffs then, since we can't buy anything.
Let's do tariffs because we genuinely have not even got that
before.
So Snuffy, are you like kind of like organizing the
customers and keeping the chaos from going crazy out there?
That was what it was wanted you to do.
I don't even know.
I don't know how to okay So somebody stopped the haunting,
but I don't know how assaulting somebody.
It definitely wasn't me We have to maybe we just assaulted
the spooky ones.
There's employees that look weird.
Oh You do that.
Oh, okay All right, I got the burgers.
I got you.
It's just no I got you.
It's just no I'm gonna put I'm gonna put this here because
it's always gonna need Yeah, one little b.
Making a little b.
All right.
I got the strawberry.
Me on the floor.
I need a beef patty.
Please don't put it on the floor.
Me on the floor.
Where else do I put it?
Actually, it's not a bad strat, though.
It's not a bad strat.
Yeah, I don't think it's a...
Do you have beef yet?
There's beef.
Yeah, yeah, me on the floor.
Me on the floor.
Cheebs.
Top one.
Where did this cooked chicken patty come from?
Boom.
Did we already cook it?
I got a little b.
bag little bay in the bag oh it's good it's done it's done
put that out there why are you throwing it all on the floor
it's efficient we don't need it's so hard to trick down what
we have a peppery breast it's efficient where else am i
supposed to put it you're making a spill you're making a
spill it adds a flavor how do i stop close this cool it's
making everything less now it's on fire Now it's on fire.
No, no, it's not.
No, it's not.
There's a frozen spill and a fire at this time.
Yeah, but it's melting.
Are you the fucking avatar of the kitchen?
The thing's on fire, by the way.
Is this done?
Oh, is this overcooked?
Oh, shit.
We have to redo it, huh?
I got a peppery breast in my bag.
How did we get so many tomatoes?
Peppery breast in the bag.
We are racing through these.
we are doing a good job see we're doing so well strawberry
jacuzzi dang everything is strawberry jacuzzi strawberry
jacuzzi i will make the dairy fairy i need a beef patty i
need lettuce patty on the floor beef patty's on the floor
you're ruining you're ruining my fantasy here man beef patty
on the floor wait until we get drive-thru for i'm just
getting into my group carries one two three tomatoes that's
bacon yeah be careful because these burnt last time yeah
oops oops oops oh i fucked them up all right let's try that
again what did i miss i need more beeps you're not doing
your job can somebody turn up the heat i'm kind of i'm kind
of chilly apparently whoa wait why is there like a fire
happening over here am i One bacon.
Oh, the restaurant is on fire outside?
Oh, wait.
Why is it on fire?
Three cheese.
How do you make a strawberry?
Bacon cheese.
What did I miss last time?
Onions.
Strawberry jacuzzi.
One mustard.
Hot bun.
The restaurant is no longer on fire.
Dairy family in the bag.
Dairy family.
Do we have strawberry jacuzzi already?
I got it.
I got the strawberry jacuzzi.
All right, next.
Order up!
Jazzy Java Peppery Breast.
Peppery Breast?
Chicken is on the floor.
And then Jazzy Java.
Oh, you got the Jazzy Java?
That's fish.
I don't know how to get anything.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
That's chicken.
Chicken.
Two bacon.
Lamal.
Be patty on the floor.
I gotta put chicken patty here on the floor.
On the floor.
Yeah, see, like, where else was done?
Peppery breast is in the bag.
We need a...
There you go.
Nice.
Or up.
Vigley, pigley, pigley, pigley.
Does that feel like the bouncer?
Yeah.
It's nobody is like...
It's fighting people outside.
It's like only paranormal activity comes from my hires.
I think I threw something into the void.
I'm gonna just wipe that.
Yeah Okay, there's some cheese on the floor cheese on the
floor pork Okay, the pork keeps phasing through the fucking
burger a lot of pork.
I have another pork here It keeps going through the thank
you.
I got the pork.
This is a fish patty.
It kept flying through the fucking burger.
Thank you There we go We're doing so well.
Onion, mustard, mayo, top bun.
Yeah, I already got them in the bag.
I've got more salmon nuggets on the floor.
In the bag, burg, bag.
Let me get that for you.
How may I help you?
Welcome to Snoppy Sisters.
How can I help you?
Burger, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg,
burg, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg, burg.
It's all right.
I'm here.
Fun bottom.
We're here!
That's pork.
Uh...
That's beef.
Can you guys spit on?
Okay, thanks.
I'm pouring on the floor!
Oh no!
I'm really using lettuce.
If only everybody could just spit on...
Uh...
And where I'll spit on you.
Do you want me to try?
Why does it have to be in the exact order?
I know it's so annoying, actually.
I got the lettuce.
Oh, nugs.
Oops, you keep throwing the lettuce.
Thank you.
Beef.
Where the fuck did my beef go?
the beef teleporting beef on the floor i got it
i think you're slacking a little bit management told me i'm
gonna go use i'm gonna use the other station because my beef
is teleporting over there yeah i don't know paranormal
everything's fine for me i hear a man i who pushed me who
pushed me i i think you're hallucinating no one else trying
to get Mayo and I put the ketchup on.
Do we have a fire on the roof?
Guys, I don't mean to alarm.
Dairy fairy.
What's a dairy fairy?
Okay, I'll make the burger.
Don't worry about it.
I'm making burger, burger.
No, I'm making burger.
No, I'm making burger, burger.
Who's got the dairy?
Where's my burger?
I think I can hide in here when the demon comes.
Nobody's making the dairy.
sorry i'm on the roof i'm making a dairy i'm part-coring
right now what's the dairy fairy dairy fairy all right i can
do sorry i can do the dairy fairy i was i was busy getting
like yelling at dokey i'm doing the bird i'm i'm technically
the model employee right now i i will say everything is on
the floor because of you i got a vocal flavor they don't
care What?
No, where did you get a Funko Pop?
On the roof?
It'll help us from getting exercised.
Alright, I'm making Burger Burger.
I'm making Dairy Fairy.
I'm dancing and entertaining the audience.
Onions, mustard, hot bun.
Dairy Fairy, come on!
Burger, Burger coming up!
There we go, we did it!
Yippee!
How may I help you?
Agent Orange Welcome to Sloppy Sisters Dairy Fairy!
Is anyone else seeing the money go up at all?
Where is our money?
Bottom my corner, mine still says zero.
Well, it's because we haven't been paid yet.
Well, it's because you gambled all your fucking money away.
Oh yeah.
But how can we tell what the quota is and when we meet it if
the money never changes?
Maybe it's how much, how many customers we serve.
This is a big order, big order.
I'm making a Dairy Fairy.
You're making a Dairy Fairy.
Am I not doing it right?
You're just giving the food away for free or something?
You're not even taking money.
You're just giving them food?
Yeah, I won't be surprised honestly at this point.
Hey, what do you mean?
You won't be surprised.
I won't be surprised.
Am I the problem?
Stuff's teleporting again.
I got each in orange.
Oh Okay, you are the jazzy Java.
Jazzy Java.
Okay, you're just missing.
I got the jazzy Java.
We just need the dairy fairy.
Yeah, we're live and we're waiting on you for the dairy
fairy The fucking beef is teleporting again.
We're just waiting for you on dairy fairy You know maybe
libel should be on like No, I can't I it's do you see the
all the meat is clipping through the fucking wall here?
I think she's like I can't see it actually though.
Yeah, I think I actually don't think we should stop throwing
things on the floor Because it's like freaking you're just a
hater you're a hater I'm throwing away all of the dirty
meat.
Why are you throwing them away?
Because it's freaking out!
You're just jealous that I'm a better employee than you.
I'm going to throttle you.
I'm technically doing three jobs right now while you're
doing one.
That's all I'm saying.
This is me all over the floor.
Okay, she's hallucinating me.
Yeah, she's, yeah, she's just gonna look crazy.
The meat is floating.
Yes, the meat is floating.
Oh, wait, no, I didn't get it.
Oh, man, what'd you do, Stuffy?
What'd you do?
What did you do?
I don't know what I did wrong.
I didn't know what I did wrong.
I'll give it, I'll try it out.
What do we need?
We need a beef patty.
We need a beef patty right here.
Beef patty, not on the floor this time.
Okay, I got it.
Bacon.
I got the bacon.
Oh, okay.
And then three cheese.
Three cheese.
Okay, you can do it.
You grab three at a time.
What are you doing?
Does anybody want to pay me?
Three.
Tomato.
I'll take you into the bathroom.
Oh my god.
Onion.
All right, you got the mustard and the top bun.
I don't like that you can't see what's already in the bag.
Is there anything in the bag?
Yes, you can.
You can see it right here on the tablet.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
the rest of us is better at this game than limo that's all
i'm gonna say oh we met the quota wait wait wait we didn't
get any money wait no no let's keep doing more orders
because we're looking we're doing overtime i'm going to try
and make a burger and see if it cooperates and i just down
the coffee i'm ready to fucking cook i'm ready to all right
we need a jungle cola two jungle cola freezes i'm making one
i got it just it just it just it's not working who's making
the burger Uh, Lamo.
She's so- Don't- don't make her do it!
Don't make her do it!
Alright, Lamo, you're off of- Someone's gonna do burgers
now.
Lamo, you're off of- You're off of Burger Duty.
We don't even need to do this.
Let's just- Yeah, look, it's so much time!
Oh, shit!
We should close and reload the restaurant so I can fucking
make things again.
Turn up kitchen appliances.
Oh, there's every- All the fires.
Oh, fuck.
I just threw the thing at the fire.
Oh.
Oh, there's- There's little brains rolling around you guys.
careful it's normal my training things are yeah turn off
turn off check this all right my basketball training guys my
basketball training brain this is why this is why I play oh
my god the brains the brains the brains the brains trash
disposal you can call me where's the thermostats I'm trying
to take out the Oh, I'm on fire!
Someone's not...
What's a thermostat?
What is the thermostat?
Where's the thermostat?
Guys, it's camping me.
Oh, I got one of them.
I got the thermostat.
Kitchen appliances.
I'm trying to get the trash.
That looks off.
I got the thermostat.
I did the trash.
That doesn't matter.
Oh, big cows here.
Big cows here.
Okay, I turned everything off.
I turned everything off.
We just need the thermostat.
I'm trying to find the last one.
I got one.
of them oh i got one oh wait no that's not it wait where's
the fire i got one of your thermostat i don't know what the
other one is i'm on fire i can't see the other thermostat
has anybody it glows red it glows red you'll know when you
see it glow red i'm trying to put you out it doesn't seem to
work i'm trying to put out the place but it doesn't yeah i'm
walking around
It's like in different houses.
Why isn't it working?
I got another.
Wait, there's one more somewhere.
It's in the house somewhere.
Fucking crink.
Oh my god, you just gotta find it in the house.
It's in the house.
I don't see it.
There's one here, but I don't know how to turn it off.
How do you see it?
You have to calibrate it.
You can see a number on the top, right?
You can see a number, you just do it until the number.
I found another one.
That's already done.
Ah!
I got another one.
Oh my god.
There's so many thermostats!
Oh come on!
I got another one!
Oh my god.
Get to the elevator!
Go go go go!
Escape!
Go!
Go going!
Oh my god.
Check that out.
No!
I know, please!
Yeah!
I live!
Yeah, I think I need to like I think I need to reconnect
also It doesn't attribute anything to anyone except for
doki.
Yeah He cooked 35 things and got all the money Look at that.
Look at that.
I told you I was doing my job.
I need to reconnect to the game because everything's out of
sync from her.
It's all decent for me I think she cooked all the patties.
Yeah, I think that's true My patty all over the floor.
But yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna reconnect to the lobby.
Could you re-invite me?
All I'm saying, I think I'm employee of the month, guys.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, you're also assaulting all the customers.
I ain't.
Not this time.
I was doing my job.
You know what I'm going to do with all this money?
Wait, wait.
Well, it's time.
It's my turn to Gamba.
I want to watch you lose it all.
Hey, how do I...
You got money?
You made money?
Do you know how to play Blackjack?
How do I...
How did you clock in?
You click buy in.
Read she doesn't even know how to read you guys.
I don't seem to be I need to reinvite I can't I can't join.
All right, someone else.
Someone invited.
I'm gambling.
I'm gambling right now.
Hit it.
Oh That's sad
But you lost twice in a row minute.
How much that cost?
How do I invite?
I invited.
I invited her.
Okay, thank you.
All right All right, you know, it's just not letting me
rejoin anymore.
The game is cooked again.
No It's just sitting on the menu ignoring.
I'll restart the whole thing.
We'll find out.
All right.
I bet it on Merrimy.
How do you start the game for this one?
Woof, woof.
Wait, man.
How do you start the Gabba?
Oh, you just bet on the thing and then it just started for
some right somehow.
Oh Wait, wait, Merrimy.
It's my dog.
Yeah, it's my dog.
Wait!
No!
What the fuck off?
You lost your horse bets too.
Yeah, just as badly as you did.
Oh, I just threw up everywhere.
You're kind of bad at this dokey bird.
Oh yeah, yeah, I'm bad at it.
Wait, who threw up?
I just threw up everywhere.
Oh no.
Did you throw up?
You threw up.
Where did you throw up?
We gotta clean it.
What happened to you?
Oh my god, you got it all over me.
another invite yeah yeah i got you lab thank you yeah it
says i can spread an ailment to you hold on wait what spread
an ailment to me what are you doing to me do you give me the
parasite did i spread it to you dang i'm not contagious
anymore i almost had it i think lime was bad yeah lime was
bad ages did i drink like something hi i'm back where are
you guys i don't know where's the virus i'm just drinking
stuff i found out the floor smart idea good idea good idea
me too me too wait oh we can i'm ready i'm gonna put my
money in here so we can upgrade nice upgrade yeah yeah we
need 150 well it's too late i put all my money see i'm
investing in our futures unlike you guys we we aren't
allowed any money it'll goes to you for some reason.
Yeah, because you guys died.
I've got increased fun right now.
There's cupcakes on the floor.
You guys, dad.
Are you guys ready to gamble?
I'm going, oh, we're gambling.
We're going to go to hell.
I don't have money.
Let's go to hell.
I'm going to hell.
Hell.
I just smoked 10 cigarettes.
Oh, wow.
I have $0.
I mean, I feel like that's pretty accurate restaurant
simulator.
You just like drunk off your ass and you've had like an
entire pack before this fucking like shift started my inner
animal playing immersively right now yeah oh with our
presence drains oh we should do garnish wage because we're
never gonna get it wrong we workman-based gift whoa we got
cigarettes I got a bear trap I got nicotine oh my dog is
angry we we picked both we have both now I think oh we don't
know we just got toast tariffs I just got twenty dollars
wait there's a first aid kit there's a first aid kit i've
got the first aid kit for us hell yeah wait we have power
why does that why did the work mandated gift include england
flags i just saw there's a bond here they know they know
who's playing i'm gonna grab the coffee what is this oh
caffeine pills yeah unfortunately my dog cannot hear dad
right now because otherwise it would just be like an incant
recursion of dog barking.
He would be right out.
The cycle.
Oh yeah, oh, it's, there you go.
Alright, are we going?
Oh!
Are we starting a shift?
I don't know what any of these items do, but let's go.
I got Jazzy Java to go.
Hell yeah.
Are you ready?
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Did you just immediately yop, yop, yop, yop, yop, yop, yop,
yop?
Um, instantly.
Did you put those down?
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Why did I just get magnetized?
Am I okay?
What's going on?
Am I just...
Am I like...
Am I okay?
No, you're on the...
Look down!
Look down, Stuffy!
I'm like lying!
Look down!
Yeah, I got it.
I didn't want to take your job.
No, you're okay.
Do we...
I've seen them.
I don't know what to do with them.
How do we get out?
I bet you we put them in the oven.
Click on it.
Click on the thing.
Oh, you got it.
I'll do the little B.
I don't know what the others are doing.
It's probably fun.
Look, someone put the bear trap and stuffy got trapped on.
Who was the one that put down and wasted both of our bear
traps?
Yeah, who was it?
Could I have one beef burger, please?
All right.
I'm grabbing the beef burger.
I didn't waste it.
It's still here.
Honestly, they cooked so quickly, I wouldn't store too much
on the grill.
Because, like, I think it was freaking everything out.
All right.
Beef patty on the floor.
Chicken patty on the floor.
It's called my bomb.
Dang it.
Alright, I got another beef patty.
Not on the floor.
I got a cookie.
Wait, where'd the cookies go?
Over here?
In the oven?
Where'd they go?
It's here.
Where?
Right here.
We'll be in the bag.
No, that's the second.
No, they were up here and I clicked them and then they
disappeared.
Right here.
It's right here.
They're here.
Man, they're right here.
Where?
In the fryer.
Oh, in there.
know how we then pick them up i got it i just got it yeah
see this is why you're an employee of the week and you're
not getting promoted she's gonna actually kill you i think
another little bee directed towards you i've been grilling
and i forgot to okay making another little bee i need
another beef patty got the patty on the floor oh my god it's
so nice to throw a beef patty and have it actually arrive
rather than just like blinking out of existence hot rice yay
Oh, I'm getting a little dizzy.
I'm getting a little nauseous guys.
Somebody push me.
Little B is up in the bag I don't know what I turned on.
I don't know how to turn off.
What is this?
What what is that?
What did I get?
Cheese log?
Y'all need cheese log?
I do not need a cheese log.
Thank you then It's really kind of you to offer, but I'm
good.
Okay Eepsie Sammy.
Eepsie Sammy.
on the floor of course it is where else would it be it makes
a total sense honestly yeah fish patty where else would it
be or patty for patty probably a patty on the thing you know
i think that's why we have so many customers they like what
they heard of our fabled floor patties like the extra flavor
yeah i mean they are kind of freaky out there to be honest
yeah deep sea sammy in the bag Deep Sea Sammy, ready.
We have Grip?
What is that?
I already got it.
It's a drink.
Mother Clucker!
Going for Mother Clucker!
Why is that guy eyeballing me the entire time as he walked
away?
What the fuck's your problem?
I'm making burgers.
These are cute!
Oh.
Oh, hey girl.
Oh!
Whoa.
That's extra service.
Bacon.
Yeah, oh, that's true.
She's, what, being awesomed?
There are no freezers that are open.
So What are you what's going on?
Did you touch my shit?
What's ailing you bacon?
I'm on a sugar rush.
I'm caffeinated.
I have a nicotine buzz and I'm just regular buzz.
It's hard But that means you're working.
You're gonna work faster I am.
I mean I keep generating things out of this magic box.
Oh, what just happened?
I think I just I think I took damage I wonder why it's a
weird fucking sandwich.
Oh, I also have a nicotine addiction apparently
take the catおっ station.
No, my pills!
Nobody would fuck with my burgers.
No.
I think I need to go find cigarette before I die.
Wait!
I have a First Aid kit.
I need chicken.
Can you heal my addiction?
Yeah, I have a nicotine cure pills.
Wait, I actually do have nicotine cure pills!
So, me, right here!
Wait, wait, yeah.
I'm so, I'm addicted.
I'm hopelessly addicted to the nicotine pills.
Thank you.
I was dying.
I'm having a mental breakdown.
Pickles, no.
We got a mother clucker ready yet.
We're still waiting for a mother clucker.
We have a very slow employee.
Mother glaubers in here.
It's in the bag.
Put the clever in the bag.
Order up.
How can I help you?
Mother cluster again.
We need another mother clucker.
Another mother clucker.
I love making mother cluckers.
Chicken patty.
I need to put the lettuce first.
I'm doing the lettuce.
Don't worry, I'll supervise.
A chicken, bacon, cheese, hot bacon.
I never want to work.
Don't be shut.
I will find you.
I will be buying you.
is entered guys i need to take okay dokey dokey turn around
yeah okay mayo hot sauce excuse me one lime slimes hello
turn around what's up you're not you have okay okay mindo
turn around yeah i need to i'm taking everybody's duis it's
like something entered the restaurant i gotta figure
just stressing out at each other and then and then something
enter the restaurant like she's playing she's playing
phasmophobia or something how do we get rid of a ghost don't
get rid of me yeah she's like an employee i got the jazzy
java i already got the jazzy java i'm fucking you're so
fucking slow don't keep my oh my god i'm not i'm not you're
making the Chef do the other types of work.
I already had it covered.
I didn't need you to do any food.
Ah!
I feel like we can just have like a mushroom or something.
What is this?
I'm dying!
Help me!
There's an evil drone in the kitchen.
Where is Steffi?
Don't.
Steffi?
What is this?
This isn't a ghost.
This is somebody's electronic devices attacking me.
Help me!
I don't even know where she is.
It actually is.
Get out of here!
I have a bed kit.
I have a bed kit here.
You please take two.
Here, here.
A hot fries.
Here, take it.
Okay, all right, thank you.
Burger, burger, burger, burger.
Okay, make it burger, burger.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're doing a hot pie.
Lettuce, beef patty.
This one's beef, doesn't it?
Yeah, no, don't worry.
I got some more.
Hot pie.
I got a hot pie.
I got a pie.
I got the pie.
Okay, put the pie.
Pickles.
It doesn't go up there.
It goes in here.
I guess top one boom bam.
Bim.
Why don't we like pre-make burger in the bag?
The pies I got more meat.
That's not on the floor.
You're welcome.
I don't know why it sounds like fireworks keep going off Do
we have fire?
They are.
I think every time we put on put in order.
Yeah, they go off.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I'll put it.
I'll pre-make a little we need a hot pie.
I'm making it.
Doki you need to get on the same level as us you are you are
hindering this operation all i'm saying is that someone's
being really slow with the operation did the entire canteen
just like physics gmod flip out no our stability lowered and
have a little b done in the future bugger bugger bugger i
just made bugger bugger but i'll make another burger burger
for you all right i'm gonna make work i'm gonna pre-meet we
might we i think We actually need some beef.
Wait, why is this?
Why is this?
Why is this ascended?
Oh, it's burned That's why it's burned.
We need more beef.
Don't worry.
I got you a little beef little beef Why is there a raw pie
tray here?
I don't know Someone's not doing their job We made this
little bee Little beef will be I did I pre-made it.
I pre-made it Just in case That's not that's not that's a
pork that's pork that's pork He's staring at me really
scarily you guys Over here.
These are all beef.
His fists are about to be clenched.
Beef.
Tomato.
I'm gonna pre-make a burger.
That's lettuce.
Tomato.
I'm gonna make a pre-make a burger burger.
Piggles.
Pre-make a burger burger!
Burger burger coming up!
Actually, we just kinda need a burger burger?
We need it like stat?
Yeah, that was Corrin making burger burger.
Yeah.
I'm pre-making.
Burger burger.
Oh my god.
We hit our third one!
Cool to be so easy so easy wait see look at that we're
getting into the groove Uh peppery breast peppery breast uh
i'm making a burger burger Just for me it's my lunch break
okay when did you get that's my lunch break Um the boss gave
me a lunch break because i was doing such a good job Maybe
you do a better job you also get lunch break.
I've gotten like 15 500 million lunch You know, like that
one person at every job that just tries to so discourse by
like, you know, spreading misinformation and gossip, like
just like turning against each other?
Peppery breast in the back.
I'm doing my job over here.
You wouldn't even know what an order is if it wasn't for me.
Wait a minute.
Wait, but also what is Snuffy doing?
What is Snuffy doing during this?
Wait, why am I spooks?
I'm combating the forces of evil.
Guys, I'm spooks.
Why am I spooks?
What happened?
You're spooks.
ghost that's what happened i'm spooked it's really funny
spook doesn't do anything for me because i turned on i
turned on the motion sensor sorry the motion like sickness
oh yeah i turned it off too me too it doesn't do anything
for us i got it oh my god oh my god guys i think we should
close the store after i think so actually our like our
simulation security just like cratered we should close yeah
yeah there's viruses in our simulation all right extinguish
the fires oh we stalk the kitchen i got the fire the fucking
thermostats again i'm gonna start with like a thermostats
because they're in stock okay i'm doing i got one here
there's one therm oh i can ping milk button is ping i got
one of the thermostats restock box okay middle button is
ping yeah i see that one's off what That one's off.
There's nothing nothing going on here.
All right, whatever I hate it when you see the onions onion
box box of onions Hoping with trash You are not helping
there's there's there's stuff here.
Oh shit.
There's a cow I got one of the thermostats I need there's
something chasing us keep going keep going keep going keep
going What how do you find the thermostats?
Um, it's like you go around the house And then inside I
found one.
What about the items to stock the kitchen?
There's, I found one of the items.
Oh, you got it.
I found a- We need a thermostat done.
Thermostat done.
Okay, funds is necessary.
We need the- There's still one more.
I got the last thermostat.
Oh my god, wait.
Where are the- Where are the- There we go.
I got funds.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, the drone!
The bun.
What is that?
Drones!
What the hell?
I got another thermostat.
I'm so confused.
I think it's fine.
I guess.
We just got restocked.
What the hell is happening?
I'm going to die.
I'm trying to stock the buttons.
It's so fucked up here.
It's so fucked up.
There's a lot of things here.
Oh, how does the restock work?
And there's like boxes scattered around.
There's boxes scattered around.
Gotta find them and pick it up.
And then I got it.
I got VHS tape.
I did too.
Oh, okay.
See how it works.
Oh, there's something really fucked up right outside the
restaurant building.
Yeah.
I got cooked.
We need like one more restart.
Oions.
Is it the binds?
Because I couldn't do it.
Oh, we're so fucked.
It's just one box.
We're missing a box somewhere.
Oh, I see it.
I see the box.
Where is it?
It's like near the restaurant.
Wait, is that under the restaurant?
That's terrible.
There's two boxes in the restaurant.
boxes one's under the but it's not what we need we gotta
restock the onions well that's the only box I see oh there's
there's another box in there I don't know what that box is
the current I cannot do it I cannot do it
I did not see pickle box Onion box What the hell?
Guys, we all died We did, we did We're the worst of this
Fuck off, Doki Ah!
Yeah, Stuffy's the employee of the week!
Stuffy!
Yay!
I couldn't find the onions, I don't feel like the employee
why is the clean up so hard like the whole game it's
ridiculous like nothing happens and then cleanup hits and
it's just we are like split up the duties what has to be
bait I can do I can do last round last round I got one more
I got one LG LG LG let's go LG can we finish one game yeah I
want to finish one shift.
We did, though.
Remember?
We did that one time.
I don't know.
I think he wants food.
All right, you guys.
Do your work.
I'm going to feed him.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
You know, we should have a really nice and productive and
calm shift now that Doki's not here.
And then it's so quiet now.
It's so quiet here.
I'll just punch her into the corner.
I'll shove her in.
Okay.
Start your shift with a quarter of your filled.
It was a good one or a terrible one.
the one that was like yeah you get stuff done okay okay okay
it was a quarter of your quota is that what it said it said
like our quote the night shift was very efficient so our
quota is already partially all this stuff that i drink in
the lobby is still affecting me dairy fairy dairy fairy
They're very I Oh, no, God What the hell I fired you I'm
back, guys I know the manager They re-hired me It would have
been terrible without you I know I'm so good at cooking
Yeah, the manager re-hired me They're short staff They all
They all short staff They just immediately threw a fucking
chicken into the bacon They're all they have Okay, what is
beef oh we both got fries oh no double fry we're double
frying let's go also generating free also i reapplied with a
new name and they didn't background check so it was pretty
easy on the spot yeah what do you mean short staffed very in
the what does that mean a lot of patties ready potato sticks
isn't it there we go why did the drink explode it adds
flavor everything adds flavor uh that just needs a cola and
we're done cola oh i got the cola it's already there oh is
it it doesn't say it is yeah okay yeah i got more patties
being cooked uh mother clocker mother clocker all right oh
there it is uh that looks like chicken that's beef i can
tell they're just too much we burn the fuck gotta put more
nook this game sucks all right we need a mother clucker and
salmon nuggies did you burn them i am making the mother
clucker i yes how dare i was armed i wasn't extra crispy it
should be a preference that's true that's true that's double
cluck me double cluck me you know if it if something gets
burnt you there's more uh you raise the chances of getting
cancer Oh shit, I've been- I've burnt them too.
I burnt them too.
Mother clucker in the bag.
We have no nugs!
We need more nugs!
I put new nugs!
You burnt them!
Stop it!
I love working with my co- I'm with my burger workers.
I love my sloppy sisters and we're so fun.
Yeah!
It's very close to actually having a sister.
Burger, burger, burger, burger, burger, burger, making a
burger, burger.
I got the burger burger right here.
Lettuce, burgers.
I have the burger.
Okay.
I'm making the jungle cola.
Thank you.
Appreciate your help.
Did you just spit on my burger?
No, but I did it now.
And that's great.
Yeah, that's it.
People pay a lot of money for that.
Grows, suchly, onions, pickles.
Oh, whoops.
Which one's the spit?
Do not shove my burger.
Oh, thank you.
That's the spit.
Burger, burger.
In the thing.
Thank you.
Dude, there's permanently, like, white spit all over this
shopping point now.
It looks awful.
Burger, burger, burger, burger.
That is more.
Burger, burger.
It's our hot item.
Yeah.
I'm putting my burger on here.
Do not put a burger on there cheese.
I got another burger on there.
Do not put another burger on there.
Oh, whoops You know, I want to sit right here.
That's so much spit that burger is like 90% spit now.
You know, I'm pretty sure our customers.
Yeah, I pay extra for that Burger burger going in extra
seasoning What's next?
Bigly pigly pigly pigly many pigly piglies piglies you know
what i'm gonna pre-make one burger don't do it i how daring
of you that's so brave i'm so brave you're so brave how
could you bigly pigly in the bag i have it you're fast thank
you she's getting better we're doing it we're doing it over
time it's almost as though having to like scrabble around
for food on the floor makes it slower.
I don't think that's, I don't think that would be.
Dairy, fairy, fairy.
I got thinking, I got bigly, pigly coming up.
Oh, okay.
Tomato.
Oh, did somebody want that?
Onion.
Very fairy.
That team is locked in the list.
I'm scouring the premises, making sure everybody's behaving
at the burger joints.
Yeah, you should, you should.
I got one bigly, pigly.
Cheese, and then.
If we end it now, will we get tons of like money Something
is spilled?
Oh no!
I didn't do that.
We need a broom!
I'm greasy now.
I got it.
I'm going to find the broom.
I cleaned it.
I'm just a little greasy now.
Excuse me.
Oh no, you gotta take a shower.
Peppery breast!
Wait, I have... Oh, okay.
Where did my bigly pigly go?
The one I pre-made.
Oh, it's right here.
again are we all right i'm gonna make i got fish paddy
chicken bacon bacon bacon bacon bacon i'm gonna make a fish
someone could make cookies and pies oh that's true i got
pies i got cheese boom wait i can i don't have to get it one
by one i can stock it up in my inventory Did you know that?
Yes!
We don't use that!
Employee of the month!
Did you guys know that?
Do you know the basics of using your hands and feet to prep
a meal?
Yeah, but I'm the one that got very high.
Before overtime, like if we end as soon as we hit quarter,
does it make closing easier?
It doesn't seem...
It does not seem easier.
It didn't really seem to, though.
I think we spent too much on the tablet, guys.
Me too.
Those are bird droppings actually.
Mother Clacker!
All right, Mother Clacker!
All right, Mother Clacker coming up.
Oh, blob aqua, hot fries, hot fries.
I need some chicken, if you don't mind, please don't you?
I got chicken for you.
Thank you.
Is everything okay?
Did you just...
Did Minches disintegrate?
Oh.
here do you see me okay okay wait no it looks like for a
second you disintegrated i was so scared it's paranormal
activity again oh oh set me on fire why did you do no yo it
was like you stood on fire i literally saw you step there's
a fire right below you i can't see the water sorry where's
the it's lost hot fries there's hot fries in here i got the
hot fries already yeah
blob aqua all right we're done oh a simulation's about to
explode all right let's i'm closing i'm closing close close
get ready get ready all right all right what are we doing
what are we doing i'm gonna put out some fires we should
like turn things off reset the rat traps you what the hell
is that i see one i see one i'm resetting okay restocking
grease bucket what did i do did i do it restock the kitchen
oh shoot i got another mouse trap Where does the patty box
go?
I got lettuce.
I got a lettuce box.
Oh, the monsters are coming.
Monsters are coming.
Goodie.
Do you see rat traps anywhere?
It's on the floor.
It starts glowing.
I have a lettuce box here.
Then go put it away.
There's a grease bucket.
What am I supposed to do with a grease bucket?
Oh, you dispose it.
You dispose it, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm disposing.
Disposing.
I got raw fish.
Uh, where's the fish at?
Letters?
No.
Fish goes in here, right?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, thermostat, thermostat.
Looking.
I found a thermostat.
There's brains.
Can I push the brains?
I mean, you could try.
I grabbed it.
I grabbed the brains.
Thermostat fixed.
Oh!
Yeah!
Where's the thermostat?
I got one of them.
Oh, fuck me.
I got one.
We need one.
We need more thermostat.
I got the thermostat.
Where are they?
I got it.
That's a bad noise.
Run!
He was spawn capping!
Who left?
How did you guys find the thermostat?
Physics glitching over here.
Oh my gosh, yeah, I got the physics.
I didn't realize it was spawn capping.
Eeepee!
$76, baby!
Yay!
We made money!
We did it, guys!
Wait, the actual last game, we actually did it.
Oh my god.
The last game's the only best game, man.
No, you guys gotta take them out.
Invest in the restaurant.
We gotta invest.
Investing, investing.
Investing it.
Yeah!
We're tier two!
We're tier two subscribers.
We gotta be...
Burger Chan!
I wanna be Burger Chan!
We can change our masks.
Oh my god.
pizza slice and a new noise pack i get to be spooky oh i got
a to rock the warehouse and only call me this is lousy cape
i got birds
wait how are you doing the sounds there's a preview where am
i oh my god i'm stuck you guys push me out of here
I want the cat noise here.
Were you bodily function?
Yeah, that was bodily function.
bodily function i know like in locked there's more gambling
now oh wow you can buy a pizza oh but i i used all my money
so wait wait mint has money still no you told me to invest
you told me oh you invested everything oh my actually it
didn't let me have a choice of oh i believed in the
restaurant and invested i believe in the restaurant too We
should play another we should we should do a rerun of this
next time guys
Wait wait, there's a okay.
Have you guys saw the the post office game of the cats?
No, we should play that it just came out.
I found out that it's multiplayer and we run a post office I
would like to run a post office.
There's no burgers.
Yeah, I don't want to run a post office We should run a post
office to get together okay we do that sisters look on your
stamp style we're expanding the franchises we're going into
the sticky sisters yeah yeah we're expanding our business
we're going into mail now we're You, uh, Amazon.
Does that mean we have to find an appropriate alliterative
name for every business we go into?
Yeah.
Oh, hey, you pushed my beer out of my hand.
It's okay, I have cigarettes here.
I don't want cigarettes.
I don't want them.
I need to smoke.
I have a higher jump when I'm smoking.
Very good.
Yahoo.
I had a great time working with the Stoppy Sisters.
guys it's as stressful as it was yeah i'm sorry i couldn't
stay longer i have to be awake at six hours oh it's okay
have fun have fun have fun good sleep yeah good sleep oh
that's miss good night good night oh goodbye have a great
night everybody bye bye bye bye you think we can do pull off
a without limo or do we need her um she did like all the
cooking she's doing the clean and i i don't think any of us
could do the closing by herself oh no customer service
that's true that's true how fucked are we we try to close a
restaurant by herself let's see how much she carries us you
know How much is she the carry and the sloppy sisters?
I didn't even live the last game.
We still, that was still a win.
There's no way.
Yeah, no, Mitt lived.
Mitt lived, though.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, well, we got, oh, we got some presents.
She woke up angry today, Joy.
Oh, wait, that's, no, we shouldn't, that's the closing cow.
I feel like we should get the terrorists again.
Okay, yeah.
I don't even know what the shop means.
Wait, we get the pizza.
Check this out.
Oh, that's a long shlong.
We got gifts again.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, we need those because there's a test beer.
And then I got the nicotine here.
I got a bear trap.
All right, we ready?
Yeah, let's go.
Wait, we have a map now on our iPad.
What?
We have an iPad?
Yeah, you press tab.
Yes, we have an iPad.
What was this for?
All right, I got the...
Bigly, pigly, pigly, pigly.
I'm making the patties.
Someone start making...
it the burger i thought you were making the patties it's all
you you gotta make the burger now it's up you making the
fries i'm making the fries yeah i'm making a patties right
now i'm cooking the patties okay what's the burger what's
the burger we're so we're so piggly piggly okay we we we're
so all right no no we got this okay okay she can't be 90 of
the sloppy sisters surely will have a better bigger
percentage cheese tomato it's like you know how like when a
part of your brain dies the rest of the brain like uh picks
up the slack it's like that i feel like my mom just left me
somewhere and i'm not happy with it what do you mean thank
you we did it we did it we got an order yeah we got an order
see how can i serve you swimmers choice swimmers choice i
have the here fish is done dairy fairy sorry dairy fairy i
have the i have the patties yes yes yes yes yes why do you
need two drinks man i mean maybe like maybe his girlfriend
busy is for his girlfriend you know okay she's like i want a
salad but we don't serve salad jazzy java this guy don't
want a salad right now trust me we are definitely in the
united states this could be australia i don't think so i
don't think so they were these portions nah yeah they call
it the great outback that's what they call me in in the club
oh my god forgot we could have had a new location i forgot
about that oh yeah we did yeah what did we get everything
did you Did you make the dairy fairy?
Oh, Snuffy.
Snuffy.
It had it all.
We lost so much simulation.
Come on, Snuffy.
I, I, I, I, come on.
This isn't what I got hired for.
I, I was hired for janitorial duty.
Yeah, and then Lime will quit.
Are there senses to be?
And beef?
Wait, what?
I didn't know there was beef and beef.
What do you mean?
Okay, all right, all right, Snuffy.
I'll, All right, stuffy, yeah, I'm taking over.
I think you might be over.
I'm taking, yeah, I think.
I'm taking, and you're worse than me, and that's saying
something.
Oh, my, oh, my, oh.
It's all right, I'm making.
Who wants pork?
Pork burger?
That's not a thing.
What do you have never had?
What?
I'm true.
What's a pork burger?
What's pork?
Oh, what the hell?
The thing just spat out.
What?
All right, I got, I got a, I got Dairy Fairy.
Fairy fairy coming up.
That's not what we had.
The service choice is what we had.
All right, we got it.
All right.
Vegan surprise.
Fire, fire, fire.
I should make a vegan surprise.
Fire.
That's what they call me at the close.
Lettuce.
Wait, this is onion.
What did I do?
Oops.
I don't think anybody's.
Okay, okay.
All right, get out.
Snuffy.
Snuffy, snuffy.
All right, snuffy, snuffy.
Get out.
But it's a vegan surprise.
I don't even need to know what animal it comes from.
Can I use it?
We do.
Okay, I'm cooking the...
You want some pies?
The sweet pickles.
Just don't leave them.
Alright, I got the vegan surprise.
Coming up!
Vegan surprise!
We need a jacuzzi?
Oh, we got it already?
I already got it.
Alright, alright, we got it.
Mother clucker!
right up mother clucker mother clucker mother clucker and
then a chicken patty i'm gonna put the fire out don't worry
we're gonna prove la mo wrong guys we can function together
i thought you said fuck shit together like dang well that's
maybe what we're doing no we're functioning without lime
move this is life without lime this is what it's like life
without lime i feel like i'm not wearing shoes mayo hot
sauce a chopper i need a mother clucker i got a mother
clucker coming up thank you very much there you go thank you
for for coming to sloppy sisters something entered the
restaurant uh burger burger burger burger i'm gonna go fix
that something i'm good at she is so good at that okay
burger burger coming right up burger burger burger oh that's
the lettuce but where's the what is this thing get out of
here you don't belong here what is it what is it i'm so
curious what happens i got it i got it it's that evil drone
it just shows up i'm gonna start drinking i started drinking
i started drinking but we need the burger burger we need the
i'm pre-gaming i'm pre-gaming oh we're already gaming this
is the game I'm freaky.
This is the kid.
I'm freaky.
Make the burger, dokey.
I am.
It's been 30 seconds.
She's going to collapse of starvation.
God, I hope so.
I pick us.
Mayo.
You know who is really fast at making the burgers?
Limeo.
Oh, yeah.
Well, she's dead.
Burger burger.
Yeah, they got it.
How can I help you?
Bigly, pigly, bigly, pigly.
Uh, it might have been thrown up by the machine.
Uh, pork belly.
Do we have any porks left, guys?
Oh, we do.
Poor.
Guess he's in charge of that, huh?
Cheese.
Yeah, and I did have a pork.
So I'm doing my job.
What are you doing, stuffy, huh?
What's your job?
um slacking the f off because i'm cool as hell all right
bigly pigly done what if i say you're not cool huh it was
you're a poser i found john though i don't need your
validation that's what makes me cool did you serve the order
why didn't you serve it no that's not my job that was that's
what you're hired for i'm here making burgers uh burger
burger burger burger all right Do you know this would be the
perfect time to pre-make a thing, you know, that you were so
brave to say that you would do before?
Yeah, and that's what I'm doing right now.
I'm pre-making Paddy's right now.
Are you pre-making the burger burger that we need?
Yeah, I'm pre-making it right now.
Snuffy, I have to pee.
You have to take over my job.
I'll be right back.
Okay, all right.
It's probably hard.
All right, Jazzy Java.
You gotta get the Jazzy Java.
I already did that.
Hurry up the F of.
I'm hurrying.
I'm already making the next burger.
onion mayo pickup you put mayo already why did you put the
mayo over the there wasn't there wasn't that was my spit i
wasn't the mayo i literally saw i saw i saw the tablet the
pat tablet said that oh my god and i did go go make a go
make a patty go make a beef patty right now Who's making all
that thudding noise?
Oh, it's an evil- what is that?
What did he just do?
He's dropping bombs!
Hold on.
I gotta go be useful.
I hope he bombs this restaurant.
Oh my god!
No, no, not on my watch.
Wait, no, never mind, he's out of here.
Okay, well there's just like bombs around, so don't worry
about that.
Wait, what?
Why is there bombs around?
Um, I don't know.
What do I do with them?
I don't know what to do with these.
Put them in the garbage?
Oh, I fucked up again!
Oh, oh, okay.
So, so you blame me the last time and that was your first
time.
Oh, stuffy fucked me up again.
I'm dealing with the freaking bombs.
I'm throwing them away.
Hey, cheese.
If you want to go, where did this fire start?
Tomato, onion, a pickle, a mayo.
I'm still waiting.
I'm done.
I finished the burger burger.
There we go.
Why is your floating fire extinguisher?
I don't know how to put out the fire.
I'm on fire.
You serve the meal.
We better quote out.
We have to wait until Mint's back before we close up.
See, we can make quota together.
That's the easy part.
We got it.
We can make quota.
That one I'm afraid for closing.
Dairy, fairy, and...
No, we got...
Mint's got to get over here right now.
How is it going, team?
We can make quota.
We made quota.
We gotta go.
Ready?
Is everybody ready?
Okay.
I got it.
I'm scared.
I got the fire.
Dispose of garbage.
Re-stock the kitchen.
Okay.
I got the...
Oh, the cow's here.
The cow's behind me.
I'm disposing of grease.
Oh, shoot.
That's... Oh.
Oh No, where am I where am I where did I go?
You're alive.
You're alive, right?
Are you alive?
Yeah, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
Oh, sorry I got another mousetrap
How do you do the mousetrap you see it's red yeah, yeah,
it's it's flows red.
I have lettuce.
I have uh, I have uh, whoa, whoa Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
I have two pairs of food on me.
Wait, oh, I think I got it.
It's coming here.
I got a mouse trap.
I have two pairs of food on me.
Oh, bad twit.
Someone, someone get this, restock the kitchen.
I have two foods in the kitchen.
I don't know what we need to restock on.
I don't see, I'm stuck.
Oh God, I'm stuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Did anyone get the food?
Oh, I don't see.
I'm working on it.
Where's the stocking stocking stocking?
Where's the stocking stocking?
Put everything inside.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
I did it.
Did we did it?
No, there's more food that needs to be restocked.
Ah, what the go?
Whoa.
What just happened?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Wait, what just happened to me?
I just got teleported.
I got teleported to spawn, so good luck everybody else.
What else needs to be restocked?
I don't see any bones.
Is that her stocking?
Did I restocked?
I don't know!
I have a raw fish restocked!
Where's the fish?
I'm dead.
Oh my god, I restocked.
I restocked it.
Go, go, go, go, go!
I escaped!
You have to live.
I live!
Oh my god, he's in there.
He's spawned Kevin.
He spawned Kevin.
How do I make it go?
It's gone.
We all died.
I live.
See guys?
Guys.
Guys, see?
See, we can survive without libel, barely, but we survived.
I did it.
Employee of the week.
the door wait but what if there's a new location i never got
to gamble it's not worth it nothing is worth it if i don't
even make money wait 10 it's okay the house always wins the
jar to open wait how many are you donate oh i think we need
to get like oh i don't have enough it locks the new store if
i we level it up wait what do you mean it locks because then
we need to be in tier two to unlock a new we are in tier two
we are we have to ascend to tier two we're not ascended yet
oh oh I said we're tier one this is so lame you guys won't
watch me gamble who's pushing no wait who is that I gotta go
I gotta go to the toilet oh wait who are you
I thought that was a random person in our room Robbie
I'm gonna invest I'll invest I invested a little I was
useless You're stupid at investing What do you mean?
You don't even know how the money works Oh yeah?
Oh yeah?
You're the one with zero dollars Alright fine Let's sell
this one with some ball Okay yeah Yeah Alright let's sell
this Alright First one to score wins Watch this I'm about to
take over For LeBron Okay
This is my World Cup.
World Cup is soccer.
You mean NBA is Kobe.
What does it have to do with soccer?
It can be a cup.
Cups have nothing to do with soccer anyway.
Oh my God.
Can you guys just score?
We don't have our B-punches.
Where's the B-punches?
I got it.
Dude, I scored.
I scored.
That was my goal.
That was my ball.
I've lost in every game.
I've lost every way.
I have no money.
I have no ball.
I have no street cred.
You don't even have the beat box.
You can't even beat box.
All I have is the nicotine addiction.
Not everybody's born to be a baller.
Oh my God.
First try.
first try first try failed it first try oh another shot in
no you did it no you did it the score doesn't even go up
first try first try watch this first try oh my god I gave
you an assist you're welcome I assisted you did it that was
pure skill baby that was the My ball literally like hit your
ball and then it A victory spin.
Oh shit.
Oh I'm dazed.
I'm dazed.
Oh whoa.
Yeah that's right.
That's right.
Wait how do I?
Oh there we go.
That's right.
You're not safe either.
Oh my god.
Oh shit sorry.
I pushed you a little too hard stuffy.
I- Wait it won't let me out.
Wait.
Where are you?
I'm stuck in the chat box.
W-A-S-D.
This is fun, guys.
I gotta go before I fall asleep in the burger joint.
I got G-G's, everyone.
G-G.
Thank you for coming to open another franchise with me.
And also thank you to Limeo.
Another successful business.
Yeah, another successful business from the Sloppy Sisters.
customer yeah tune in next time when we open our post office
our post oh yeah oh goodbye i want to play one more time
okay all right let's watch you ball come on watch this oh
wait my game is bugged wait my game is bugged oh there it is
yeah bugged Like, no, like, for real, for real, like, chat,
I'm glad I'm streaming this.
I have witnesses.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she's lying, ain't she, right?
Oh, God!
Uh-huh.
How do you do the sound?
It's C.
Press C.
I am.
Whoa, burger chat.
Oh, oh, oh.
Why is it?
No, we're here.
Where's my burger tin?
Yes!
Ah!
Oh.
Okay, that was mine.
That was mine.
What the hell?
Ref!
She's pushing me.
Red card.
I heard your keyboard.
I heard it.
Yeah.
I hear yours too.
Oh, we can't go out there.
Wait, wait, there is another...
I just realized there's another basket.
Yeah, that's for the other side.
Oh, yeah, we're both on the same side.
We're squaring on each other.
Yeah, because we're on the same side.
Take me somewhere.
I am not.
What?
Oh!
What do you do?
It just It just teleported me when I said that Take me
somewhere I am not Oh Where did you go?
I'm at the simulation I went Wait but our mic is off I guess
I can still hear us technically right?
We're taking our data To observe the phrase is to invite it
To speak it is to awaken it I guess it was just that oh wait
what was that yeah yeah there's something walking oh no
we're safe no see nothing to worry about yeah everything is
fine yeah we're so good at this business stuff I know right
oh my god oh yeah we should open like every type of business
have you played yet no i haven't we should we should do that
we should do post office and then we should open a casino
next i think we are we are like successful business women we
should like yeah we're gonna be like we're gonna be like
what is this like korean conglomerates that own everything
don't get i'm i'm in what the fuck you're in the closet no
come into the closet what the fuck where are we what is this
game what is this game wait What is this?
The new Elysium City.
We're back in the closet.
What is this game?
Where are we?
What is?
Is this like the plan to take over the world?
I guess so.
Wait, there's stuff here.
Burger... Burger... critical threat level.
Containment.
Test subject co-op pool.
Test subject...
Oh, these must be the places we could be.
Test subject E17 data upload complete.
Oh my god, there was lore.
I thought we were just doing burgers.
Of course there's lore.
Wait, this is like, actually, do you know the original games
of this?
No, I've heard it was really popular.
Yeah, I never played it.
Me too.
It's like a solo game, too.
Wait, what does your cape say?
I went to rack the warehouse, and all I get was this lousy
cape.
Yeah, that's what it says.
Damn.
This is a creepy pasta.
This is an SCP.
The lore is deep.
Yeah, I heard like, it's like the...
Oh, have you got a DM from Garden of Bam Bam?
No.
Oh, the devs from Garden of Bam Bam DMed me.
And was like, we love your content.
Are you going to be in Garden of Bam Bam?
I guess I got to play Garden of Bam.
it oh boy you're gonna really be good at that one you're
gonna enjoy it so much wait have you played it i know about
it you want to watch me play card in the bad man no no i
don't because i don't think you'll play it when you made a
desk we're like i love your content apparently i looked at
their twitter account they follow vtubers and stuff i saw a
bunch of twitter following for vtubers yeah you jealous no
i'm watching jackie the bridge burn you're watching what
where are you watching that on the tv you can't see oh oh
wait i see you now detective jackie episode one sorry reset
it guys the reason i don't want to watch her play it is
because she will stand in the corner that's not true guys
that's not true you're a coward you're you're a coward how
am i the playing it but you're too scared don't even watch
it it'll be like a seven hour bond because that's not i'll
prove you wrong after off guy i'll prove you wrong you know
what before off guy i know your dates i don't have time
before off i guess you i saw i saw your schedule how do you
know my schedule because i'm the server stupid i literally
said i don't even have time for the cold No, no, no, I'm
looking at it.
What?
You leave on...
You have Tuesday.
What do you have on Tuesday?
I got you.
Actually, I don't remember what I have on Tuesday.
You have nothing.
Oh, no.
I don't.
I know what I have on Tuesday.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I don't.
My schedule's all messed up now.
That's right.
Guys, that's right.
You're free on Tuesday.
Garno Bam Bam.
Guys, she's such a stalker.
It's in the public server.
It's not even public.
It's in our public server.
What is happening in this movie?
I don't know.
That's episode one.
Wait, is this?
He's dead.
Oh my god, he's dead.
It's the Casablanca.
I've never watched Casablanca.
I just know it's black and white.
That's your knowledge.
Oh, they're crying.
Is he going to come out?
Oh, he's crying.
Oh my god.
Is that like a stock baby crab?
I think so.
What is happening?
No, it's just a funeral.
Nope.
It could be Casablanca.
I'm pretty sure.
They're wearing Casablanca clothes.
This game has everything.
Like, what is this game?
I got the...
I got videotapes and I got cassette tapes and stuff too.
out i don't think you get soloed this i don't know it's not
i don't think it like scales at all your your stamina runs
out so fast and you're trying to run away from the guys i
had caffeine so i just like chugged that in oh that's just
probably what you're supposed to do yeah i saved it for like
the that's why i lived okay well i'm gonna go now all right
i'll see you i'll see you on Watch you play a game on
Tuesday.
I'm going to stream on my own channel on Tuesday.
I can't watch you on Tuesday.
I can't watch you play God of Bad Bad on Tuesday.
I don't want to play it.
That's why I haven't.
Why don't you want to play God of Bad Bad?
What's wrong?
I'll DM you.
Yeah, maybe if the devs loved my content, then I would
consider it, you know, clearly I suck Yeah, clearly
Okay, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, this is my server,
you leave Okay, I'm leaving Bye.
Bye.
All right.
I mean, let's not want to do garden bad.
I'm for no gardener bad, bad guys, unfortunately.
I am relieved.
This team is crazy.
I'm so confused.
That's like, it feels like a VR chat lobby with all these
little things scattered around.
But at least we have, all right.
So we have gamble with friends and we have I got the crew
for the post office game Guys, maybe the post office game
will be easier for us There's no closing up shop So it
should be easier Hey guys, I'm gonna call it here Everybody
Was it sound okay?
I don't know Maybe my discord did reset itself when When my
discord locked everybody out Maybe that's why Because I
thought it was weird Where I basically had to boost up the
Discord a lot for when we started the stream.
Even though, like, I kept the same sound settings for, like,
the entire time.
It was fine.
Seemed good.
That's good.
As long as you guys can hear everybody.
That's what I want.
Anyways, I'm going to call it here.
As always, everybody.
Say hi, do it.
Pause, check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me.
Head to bed, because you deserve it.
Look, guys, I can play video games.
ball and gun gamer guys i say as i start playing ball i guys
look i do other video games too guys guys remember what i
used to play other games other than ball and gun you guys
remember yeah no way no way my my ball and gun player is
playing other variety games unsubscribe remember how I used
to play other video games?
We're bringing it back.
It's a throwback.
I'm so fatigued with football.
We have one more, we have two more days of football.
And we'll never see football again for four more years.
Anyways, I'm going to see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.